okay so everybody knows Michelangelo
Italian Renaissance hipster beard he's
made a few things you might have seen
this naked guy this crazy stealing a
couple of paintings but did you also
know that he is the mastermind behind
one of arts most innovative inventions
paint-by-number way back in the 1500s
Michelangelo was the man top dog he had
all the Pope's on speed-dial he was so
busy he used students to help him with
his work and he started pre numbering
sections of his paintings and ceilings
so that students could follow the design
see where this is headed back forwards
in 1949 Dan Robbins was an artist at the
Palmer paint company in Michigan and he
had an idea he created painting kids
from pre number them like Michelangelo
did and paint-by-numbers was born pretty
soon it was hugely popular seriously
everybody was doing it for goodness
sakes J Edgar Hoover havilland hanging
in the White House today Dan Robbins
with the help of the rest of us is
probably the most displayed artist in
the world
sorry Michelangelo
[Music]